yeah there it is
how spicy is too spicy today on the
burger show we're climbing mount
scoville to find out
i'm teaming up with nashville hot
chicken guru johnny ray zone from
howland rays
to try to break the world record for
spiciest burger
and who do you ask would be crazy enough
to try a 2 million scoville burger
you know those guys ethan and ela from
h3h3
and all i can say is good luck
what's the infatuation with spicy food
your chef owner helen ray is the king of
spice
and you guys are alumni of
hot ones
what is it is it like a an authoritative
thing is it like a pissing contest what
is it i think it's something that's very
addictive
um it's like instead of just going to
lunch with your homies
it's like you're going and you're
getting an experience
ethan once answered me when i asked that
he said that he loves when he feels like
he's almost about to faint oh yeah but
not painting
i feel like nobody understands that
they're just perfect to me that was
weird yeah
no but like i feel faint when i get the
perfect amount okay
we're using uh today we're doing a
szechuan peppercorn in uh this burger
and
that has a numbing sensation in your
scalp where it feels like your scalp is
kind of
raising you know so not only will you
get that kind of faint
almost collapsing feeling but on top of
it
your scalp will be kind of uh raising
and your eyebrows will be just too much
right good well we'll see we'll see
about that what level of hot is this
thing that we're looking at right now
that one i think is a medium uh just a
baby starter piece
eel get out of the way too oh and what
level is this two out of six
six oh [ __ ] but on the six there's
something special you have to sign a
waiver
and you have to kind of prove that you
can handle it because we don't want to
just
we've had people get sent to hospitals
oh my god have you ever been sued or
threatened with litigation
no we're pretty good about it i'm going
to sue your ass after today
they signed uh not for you yeah just a
release no it's a llc umbrella so the
the last llc the burger show it was nice
being on this show
so here's today's challenge we're about
to make a spicy ass burger hopefully the
world's spiciest burger i think so
and uh you guys get to eat it i'm
excited and i'm ready
yeah let's get that frozen toilet paper
ready
because it's gonna be that kind of yeah
so we're in the new burger lab you're
the king of hot
let's make the world's spiciest
hamburger
what i have is a american wagyu
thick patty not too thick but it's a
good enough substantial piece of meat to
like convey the heat
yeah what makes me worried initially is
looking at all of
like the fiery hot looking things right
we have
hot mayo powders we have chili seasoning
we have the chili oil but when you
really can
teeter-totter on the fine you know
string and balance
the different elements of spice
jalapeno's right here yeah okay
ghost is like right in the heart goes
and it gives you anxiety because pepper
it's like oh and then you start getting
anxious yeah right and then trinidad
scorpion is
very similar to the szechuan in a sense
it's very mental but when you couple all
these different
sensations that um all these different
peppers have
and and really can fine-tune it it's all
about the harmony of food
in your case the harmony of spices yeah
i feel like we need to protect up
yeah and throw some gloves on for sure
you had a cool idea to
kind of introduce some szechuan
peppercorns to it and i i definitely
um wanted to rip on that we're going to
hit him on all kinds of angles
but we're still going to make it taste
amazing yes
i'm going to hit it with a little salt
mixed with chili powder are we good
camera's ready it's going to get really
red in here
and also your ventilation is good this
might light the whole room up oh let's
do it okay
dude it looks like
we have a blend uh ghost pepper trinet
scorpion
two types of habanero uh carolina reaper
and we made a special blend for the
burger show
we're gonna do a little bit of this on
top but we're gonna add just a little
bit right now
so this is monterey jack cheese there's
some peppers in there
a hawaiian sweet roll bun and then this
is your
patented come back sauce that's right so
this naturally goes
really well with spicy food it's kind of
like tangy
it's got a little sweetness to it i made
a little bit of it's like a
banana chilies and red onion pickled
i figured it has heat but it also has
acidity to like
cut through the richness of um the wagyu
yeah i was thinking uh dripping a little
bit of that
i want to see the violence oh my god and
then
this is this is already i already know
it's gonna be fantastic
look at that a little bit more of that
check this out power and raise spicy rub
watch this this is a little secret one
just for that tingle well it's already
got the tingle but look
one two that's going to be in each bite
that's it that's all you need is just
one
kill you're gonna pop it they're gonna
pop it and then they're gonna be like
what is that
so this is this is very hallucinogenic
burger we're gonna call this
the burner burger the burning burger i
think they're going to really enjoy the
flavor i bet there's going to be a
comment of like
um oh that's do you think we should try
it
oh
[Music]
i just touched i just tasted the oil
his eyes oh man uh
yeah good luck
[Music]
we present to you the burner burger
you have a beyond burger and you have a
american wagyu burger yeah you got to
glove up
yep yeah although he's a preference
person
what do you think as the pepper
professor
i mean it depends on the level of
enjoyment
why are you wearing gloves because i was
cooking this and i'm going to eat it is
that more dangerous
put the gloves on i feel completely
honored that you guys both
in collaboration cook this burger for me
yeah this is a this is the first time
i've ever super excited
i have to say it that i am a huge fan
i'm a burger boy as ila knows
i would eat a burger for every meal if i
could humanly survive
so i i consider this a true blessing and
privilege
so on a scoville scale like if you're
measuring heat
you know like like jalapenos ring in at
like you know anywhere a thousand
something like that this is going to be
uh roughly 2 million
200 000 jalapenos yeah i know i'm trying
to do that it's like taking
one jalapeno and intensifying it by two
hundred thousand that means i'm gonna
die that means my head will just
melt well no you guys have the bomb yeah
you guys are problems you know like
that's like
this and this is to a million so i have
the green light you got the button to
save yeah you're good
you can even rub it in this look at that
if you want i'm not doing that
look at that it's like uh snow cheers
i'll see you on the toilet later bon
appetit
what do you guys think what's going on
what's happening oh my god i feel like
going everywhere
like it's because there's so many yes
he's feeling it i feel that when i feel
the flavor forget the spice you're gonna
make a good
flavor
it started slow but it's like yeah it's
it's only going it's like a
orchestra let's see that second bite
yeah there it is there
nice cook on it yeah it looks great yeah
how are you doing the pickles
i'm dying huh
[Music]
i think we did it yeah i mean we wanted
we wanted to get that yes yes one of the
third yes
i do want another bite yeah but i feel
like i can't
right here think like over here
[Applause]
just like dip it in oh the dip
hey this is really good actually i'm
actually really impressed
you get a starting to fill the numbers
oh [ __ ] did you get the sichuan
i'm like man i'm enjoying this i don't
know how you're gonna move it
my lips i feel like i just gave satan a
deep throat [ __ ]
yeah i do feel that i just got blue
cocky by [ __ ]
all the demons okay did you get this guy
oh my god you're like it's in my throat
i mean i feel bad
i got that right
and it just keeps going and you want to
stop but it doesn't
on the surface though you look very calm
because i don't show i don't show a lot
but i i'm going through a lot right now
uh-huh i'm enjoying myself like this oh
you're in a place right now yeah
i'm just thinking about things he gets
your house and high off of this [ __ ]
i'm in pain did you put something
i i had a little panic attack for a
second there wow
because my stomach was it was like it
was going like this whoa i was like whoa
where my fingers are numb right now
you're wearing gloves
nope they're like i'm transcended
i'm immune
your bottom lip is shivering she's cold
no i don't think she's cold it looks
like she's [ __ ] she's cold
i don't know you're not cold she's
shivering i'm a little cold oh you are
cold yeah
what's happening to you well i'm like
it's not cold though your body's in
turmoil what did you do to my poor wife
you psycho what's wrong with you
this is
you hit the hottest sauce on hot ones
yeah and you are having
a meltdown you're having like a yeah
full-blown mug
yeah yeah what is it i think that hits
harder than any of the hot ones
yeah yeah i feel like we just took like
a peyote spirit
retreat i'm telling you bro you two guys
had bad dreams
you guys had really bad treasures yeah i
mean you were coming yeah
we had a really good time i i don't
think we should ever serve this
i don't know i think they live here
it's the mic drop and it's done i don't
know if people can people people
i don't think that this would be a
health concern yeah they're not ready it
will be
this is
if shawn evans wants us to make one
we'll make him one yeah
because he's the spy story john gets
them and he should try this and i think
he's never had anything
he should be elected if anybody else and
chile class the homie chili class
he would love this maybe i'll make it
for us three but anybody else i don't
know if i would give it to you
we just made burger show history h3h3
johnny ray's own world's spiciest burger
that was awesome
we will always remember this we will
yeah we'll remember this
yeah i feel like we should have been in
joshua tree right now
yeah exactly
[Music]
psychologically yeah because it takes
like you're worried about two of these
they call me in the morning yeah do you
see that
did you see there's [ __ ] hot sauce in
the ice cream and i'm like oh
i'll give you some b-hole roll what's up
everybody thank you for watching the
burger show
make sure you hit that like button make
sure you smash that subscribe button
hit that notification bell if not for me
for the burgers thank you